why did the relationship end I just
think sexually no no because you said go
ahead because what why did the
relationship end I'm Eric I'm bisexual
I'm here today to talk to two of my exes
I'm 28
no no no I was bisexual just about all
my life my experience dating as a
bisexual it's been a bit difficult
mostly dating women as I think the
hardest part my name is Mariah and I'm
26
I dated Mariah for about a year and a
half we've been broken up for two and a
half years my name is Alexander and I'm
36 I did Alex for about a year and a
half we've been broken up for about
three months now I'm hoping to get a
little bit of exposure to the bisexual
part of the spectrum I feel especially
as a male there's not a lot of people
that are open about it just trying to
bring that to light
what attracted you to each of us Thanos
has tried to buy you first physically
whether you were definitely my type
curvaceous smart both of you
and yours were funny because were just
good conversation how did you feel when
you found out I was bi I mean for me it
was a surprise because you didn't tell
me until like way later and so having
had zero experience and then you just
like popping it up after we had already
been seeing each other for a while it
was pretty surprising I just felt like
it's kind of one of those things he like
tell someone who just preference yeah
I'd never dated anyone bisexual I guess
it's like you're gay to guys a woman I
was just kind of like oh that's like
interesting and new whoo yeah you know
just take him especially because it was
so late in the game I think as I was
like really in like the queer circle so
I'm like I didn't want you to question
my masculinity yeah that and it was
difficult having this life for somebody
for eight years and then I ended to be
with her and it's just seeing like
friends with that were friends with him
which is the whole gay circle everybody
knew that I was with this guy how did
you how do you take that I stopped
talking you did I stopped talking
because I had no idea about any of it I
didn't know he was by I didn't know he
was with a man I didn't know he left
that relationship for me I had no idea
Alex how did you feel about me going
from dating a woman to dating you you
had told me that you were in a
relationship with a guy for eight years
yeah you'd also were very honest and
truthful about leaving him for Mariah
and I had no problems with it like I
said if he had told me months later
after I got to know you and everything
that we had done yeah I wouldn't have
believed you because there was nothing
about you or anything that you did you
know that encompassed or incorporated
bisexuality at all yeah I feel like you
just jump into whatever
you jump into like full force like if
you're gay then you're gay but if you're
with a woman then you're with a woman
the essence of your bisexuality is like
you're going full force with whatever
you're feeling at that time no no no
like I say fully committed I would agree
with that because there was no sign of
me to see that there was anything that
would give me anything that he was
bisexual that was the same for me it was
like you you were with a man why do you
think he had that I think he had a lot
of misconceptions about how I would
perceive him as a man if he was open
with me about his friends or his
preferences that's one of my biggest
regrets is just like not being able to
involve her as she should have as like
every part of my life because I loved
her and I wanted her involved in
everything were you ever concerned I
wouldn't fit into your life I was very
concerned not for anybody else but you I
don't worry about anybody else's like
ideas about what this was attitudes
towards like are you really by and like
are you just unsure or like none of
those phased me I just didn't want to
affect you and now I feel that me hiding
it led to more thoughts with you because
there's an uncertainty I'm just sorry I
just didn't involve you with every
aspect of my life as I should have and I
would have loved to I think you would
have accepted it fully you're very open
with me and I should have been
completely open with you when you closed
me off to certain aspects of your life
it made me felt feel like you were
keeping something from me yeah did you
ever felt like I was cheating with you I
felt like what reason would there be for
you not to introduce me to that aspect
that side of your personality other than
something else is amiss like what could
you be hiding from a work perspective
from friends that you were making you
were not open about it I feel like you
kind of go back and forth proud not
proud proud not proud and like it's kind
of circumstantial at times
what was it like for you the first time
I met your straight friends no I did not
meet other than your family I did not
meet any straight at all of yours there
was no heterosexual lifestyle or
community that he was involved in at all
it was just he was a gay man to me who
had a bisexual experience with a female
now that you're single do you think that
you sway one way or another are you open
to both or usana both yeah and when I'm
single yeah I'm single I'm just gonna do
I don't just go to gay events I go to
straight events I do everything like
I've seen him talk to both within his
realm of bisexuality it's just who he's
with it's like he's catering to that do
you think the fact that you're bi
affected our sex life a first year for
sure I was very much in my head a lot I
just didn't know I guess had a reactor
what to do because like in sex I'm like
dominant um you know the one on top I'm
like the aggressor we definitely didn't
have any of that I would say the nature
of our relationship was very much a
partnership a very very affectionate
caring partnership very filled with love
100% like there were just times we would
just hang out and like stare at each
other
it wasn't very sexual yeah I don't think
yeah and it's it's so strange to me to
hear this because he constantly wanted
to have sex what he said what he's into
and like the aggressor and whatever
because I took on the dominant role and
I was the dominant one in the
relationship it was difficult for me to
see him as the dominant person
did I fit your image of what you thought
a man should be I don't have any
perception of what a man is I guess I
felt like I had to take care of you a
lot more so than I would have liked and
that was something that I felt kind of
stemmed from him being bisexual and like
being with men before me because I felt
like he was the submissive in previous
relationships because I was forced out
of my comfort zone for the first time
whereas I like to be catered to I don't
know if you would call that a feminine
role or whatever it is but yes I do like
to be catered to ooh I like to be taken
care of I like to be led and with him it
just felt like he kept trying to assume
this role that didn't suit him do you
feel like you were more catering to him
or like more like you took care of him I
usually take on the more masculine role
dominant masculine temperamental and I
feel like kind of dominated that with
Erik I just think from being in that
relationship that I was with with the
man it was kind just like I took care of
myself he took care of himself and I
didn't just grasping that like I was
just like I should just be watching out
for her like let her enjoy herself
[Music]
why did the relationship end we got into
an argument things escalated and it
turned pretty bad so and no no because
you said go ahead because of what why
did the relationship end which time when
it ended I made out with two guys I was
upset and and I made out with somebody
that he wasn't too fond of someone gonna
ask some guy that he used to date
we're relationship lines were that was
kind of difficult I'd like to answer
that by saying I ended the relationship
but it has absolutely nothing to do with
Eric being bisexual that was not a
factor whatsoever
why didn't we work my machismo my my
jealousy my drinking I just think I had
really bad behaviors with you I just did
what I wanted to with that thought you
know I was just enjoying myself when
really I should have been taking care of
you I'm catering to you and not being
that way and or just enjoying things
together exactly yeah yeah I didn't I'm
so I'm sorry for the way that I behaved
with you it wasn't called for the
jealousy had no no no packing like when
we were together we were together or
together hundred percent all of those
things stemmed from your own personal
view definitely Duff I never did those
things I think with just trying to be
dominant trying to be have that machismo
getting up in people's faces if I see
them doing something being the aggressor
I think that in part add a little bit of
do with it but overall I think it's just
a character flaw that I have outside of
my sexuality
how will has being with me change your
perspective on bisexuality Eric is my
third bisexual encounter and I wouldn't
say that it has changed my perception
I completely wholeheartedly believe that
bisexuality is real and I dated these
guys who definitely showed me the kind
of fighting with their inner selves and
mentally like who they are and is this
who I am and I think that the bisexual
community gets a bad rap from both sides
heterosexual community and the homeless
community and it sucks they're in this
kind of like mold and and they're
discriminated against and it's something
that if a heterosexual person is going
to question how could somebody be gay
Who am I to question how somebody could
be bisexual because I cannot answer how
I am gay and so I cannot question how
someone's bisexual you experienced a gay
man
I pretty much experienced a straight man
for the most part like in everything
that he gave me was a straight man
although I have my own thoughts with you
specifically that don't reflect the
bisexual community or even the gay
community or anyone for that matter
interview you Eric as a person he was
given me my own perspective on you asked
for bisexuality people find beauty and
what they find beauty in and I'm not
anyone to say anything I just didn't
want you to think like he's gonna cheat
on me with the guy you know this is who
he is like I don't want you to question
me I don't know I liked I liked who I
was even after and like you made me feel
really good about it
even though you liked men too
are you guys feel tired and hungry
[Music]